spoilers ahead
click away if you haven't seen the movie
and don't complain in the comments
section if you're still here after this
warning
okay most of us has brought in its apex
movie the one that tops them all
and yeah that's a pun and we've done
this in two other videos
and in this movie there are a wide
variety of scenes some that are great
and some that you just want to skip the
human storyline mostly
but there are ones that are just
outright brutal and makes me want to
rewind and play and rewind and play
again
so in this video we will showcase our
list of the top 10 most brutal moments
of godzilla vs gong so let's get down
with this sickness
number 10 the scene where godzilla
destroys all the ships
this scene comes at the 10th spot but is
totally awesome as godzilla
just slices a destroyer and breaks two
others with his tail
and not to mention dragging one of them
underwater but the best one is him
firing the atomic breath on the aircraft
carrier that [ __ ] is just lit
it just lit up the sky like the 4th of
july or diwali in india
number 9 godzilla fires the atomic
breath to the hollow earth
this one was just epic and shows how
powerful godzilla really was and how
much energy he wasted
which could have been devoted to i don't
know maybe destroying mechagodzilla
anyway he just dug the hole right to the
center of the earth
the freaking center of the earth that is
power incarnate
number eight gong kills the warbats this
scene was
at first chilled with the humans and
kong traversing the plains of middle
earth
oops i mean the hollow earth until smaug
i mean
the warbat just came out of nowhere and
kong killed the first one by impaling
its head right on a sharp rock
and next one by falling and breaking its
wings then ripping its head off
and then drinking its brains like a
smoothie mmm
proteins juicy
number seven godzilla drowns kong this
scene right here follows the number 10
spot where
right after destroying the aircraft
carrier godzilla spared no time in going
back for kong and then
even though corn managed to kick him for
the side for a bit
godzilla was relentless in the attack
and wrapped his tail around
kong dragging him down like a thick
siren
serenading the sailor comb into the
depths of the ocean
number six godzilla vs mechagodzilla the
beam duel
well what do you know godzilla vs kong
also brought in
something that has been missing for
years on the big screen
the kamehameha duel on one corner we
have the mecca with the red spiral beam
attack
and on the other is godzilla with his
iconic atomic breath
and both of them fight at the same time
like
a dragon ball z climate scene oh it was
good
number five the godzilla atomic breath
versus gong axe
on this spot we have uh one that was
seen right from the first trailer
from january and that is the axe versus
atomic breath scene but this scene was
the climax scene of kong brutally
dominating the first round against
godzilla
the axe and breath exploded on reaching
critical limit exploded and pushed both
tithes hundreds of meters away from each
other
at number 4 mechagodzilla dominates
godzilla when the mecca finally made its
way
from the underground facility into the
surface it was instantly met with
godzilla ready to take him down but
instead
of having a one-on-one challenging fight
the mechagodzilla surprised
us all by absolutely pulverizing
godzilla's face and downright dominates
the big g
godzilla's superior indeed at number 3
we have godzilla going
exorcism mode on kong the scene follows
right after godzilla is taken down by
kong
and the axe explosion here godzilla
walks on all fours and even though he
was sneaked attacked by
kong he went on full rage mode on kong
on all fours like a rabbit dog
like he was possessed by valak or some
demonic entity
brutally attacking kong and scratching
him his chest and ending his heart beat
with a foot stomp at the number two spot
we have kong ripping mechagodzilla's
head
the second spot here is kong fighting
against make a godzilla and getting his
axe supercharged by godzilla's atomic
breath
he went on full viking on the robot
slicing his arms then his legs then his
spine
and ended up in ripping the mecca's head
off its body
thankfully he didn't eat it like the
warba iron isn't really
titan's preferred flavor and number one
mechagodzilla kills the skull crawler
now this deserves a spot of the most
brutal moment of godzilla versus scorm
we were first expecting the red
skullcrawler to be a tough challenger
but
had absolutely no chance to even move
when it was stretched out by mecha
godzilla
then the mecca fired its red beam attack
right into the mouth of the skull
crawler
and then sliced its body right down the
middle right down the spine with its
deadly beam
now that's brutal and so with that we
conclude our top 10 lists of the most
brutal godzilla vs skull moments
do tell us if you want to see a top 10
best moments of godzilla vs scorm
or the best atomic breath scenes of the
monster verse
anyway click that like button for
support and subscribe if you haven't
to be a part of the minecube family and
smash that notification bell for regular
updates on monsterverse and godzilla vs
comp videos
right here on minecube take care fam